J what is the number-one most exciting
thing J yeah
[Music]
Goodin Turk with the cast of Super
Troopers - okay first question
all-time favorite broken lizard moment
is when you give landfills eulogy in
Beerfest and you say he laughed so hard
he shat a plum and then you say I was
plumb surprised interesting because we
did a version of that that was so sad
and emotional the studio asked us to
reshoot that so he came up with the
comedy version of landfills eulogy Jake
what is the number one most exciting
thing J yeah yeah don't turn your back
on me shadow sec yeah what is the most
exciting thing about Super Troopers -
the size of my mustache women and men
are gonna run screaming towards me so
irresistible you had to shave it for the
press tour you're no dummy alright Jay
Jay yeah I hear ya over here I'm
listening okay talk to me what's the
most embarrassing thing that has ever
happened to you when I was in high
school
some guys emptied two tubes of
toothpaste on me in the middle of the
night
I thought someone had vomited on me so
then I woke up and ran into the hallway
and vomited into a garbage can and
everyone down the halls like what it was
just toothpaste and now I can't use gel
toothpaste to this day I thought it
might be that he nicknamed himself
wheels because he was supposed to be the
fastest guy in the neighborhood but then
Steve Flemmi beat him in a footrace
I turned my back on you my father's
because the time in when we lived in New
York City where you thought you were
buying a VHS player off the street of a
guy in an alley and you brought it home
and it turned out to be full of bricks I
thought it was the time when you showed
up for the reshoot in hives covered in
hives no I turned my back on you hello
turn my front to you between Paul Kevin
myself and Steve Steve that's what I
thought
who is your favorite
they already said it here he said he
said I guess you're a very good director
John always felt I stick with my answer
thank you you're my favorite lizard -
James well I changed my answer what this
has been getting turnt with the cast of
Super Troopers -
[Music]